for the philly zach wheeler makes his
first start of the season
season number two in philly's pinstripes
wheeler last year was terrific a 2-9-2
era in his 11 starts
and he'll go to work against the braves
here this afternoon
ron lacuna had a very good opening day
gonna miss a hundred miles an hour one
out here in the first
100 at the letters you're not going to
catch up with that
what a way that'll bring up ozzy albee's
in the air to left center fields
it's not deep playable for mccutcheon
but he makes the catch two outs freddie
freeman on opening day was over four
with a walk
back toward the middle knocked down by
wheeler in the top of his glove he
corrals it and the inning is over now
that's a quick first
inning 13 pitches we're out to the
bottom of the first
charlie morton who makes his return to
the braves
pitching for atlanta after signing a
one-year deal in the off-season
atlanta being the team that originally
drafted charlie borton
and brought him to the big leagues for
the first time all the way back
in 2008. fitch to mccutcheon
is on the ground and angry with a
backhanded stab one pitch and
one out mccutchen's retired for out
number one works to reese hoskins here
on the ground riley's got a big hop
and a strong throw to first takes care
of hoskins two ground ball outs two down
there's bryce harper
as bryce harper goes after the first
pitch and whacks that past freddie
freeman and cooney got to it quickly
360 spin his throw headed towards second
and bryce harper is going to be
tagged out great play by acuna to hustle
to the corner
and he's able to throw out bryce harper
who tried to stretch a single
into a double wow that was a great bit
of work in right field no score marcelo
zuno will lead off for
atlanta swinging a miss 98 second
strikeout
for wheeler ball really moving it's hard
to believe you can throw that hard and
make the ball sink like that
ground ball over to third bone stays
down on it
in time to get austin riley
no runs one hit and a man left a couple
strikeouts for wheeler through two
charlie goes to work versus romuto shot
the other way and face it for real mutzo
third hit of the season and brings alec
baum to the plate
balm on the ground dansby tricky hop
feeds ossie for one
and in plenty of time for the double
play so there's the sinker for charlie
morton ground ball specialty two for the
price of one
charlie morton threw two innings one
strikeout three singles
and that'll bring up zach winner
three-two pitch
got him swung on a miss good fastball
that tailed away
second strikeout out of morton back to
the top of the order to mccutcheon as
charlie's in search of his first one two
three inning
swung on and missed got a fastball by
him upstairs
and a one two three inning out of borton
he has three strikeouts thus far
one down now for bryce harper harper's
singled back in the first inning but he
decided to test the arm of ronaldo cuny
and probably wishes he hadn't
as ozzie diving play from the grass robs
harper to hit good play
charlie morton's gonna love seeing that
all summer long and just like that he's
set down six in order
zach wheeler to face travis darno to get
it started here in the fifth
strike three slider on the outside part
of the plate
five strikeouts for zach wheeler here's
the 2-2 pitch to swatson
swing gonna miss 99 on the fastball
six strikeouts for wheeler and a call
strike three
went with the slider and he got him
looking seven strikeouts
for zach wheeler phillies will have
runners on first and second
two outs here in the fifth best threat
of the day by either side
well you like your chances with wheeler
see if zach wheeler can help himself
here
but he loops one out to center field
that's a base hit
it past the diving all these sador is
going to score
rbi single for wheeler and the phillies
are on top one to nothing
that's why they hit batsman was oh
so costly ball four and all this trouble
with two out
and the bases will be loaded for reese
hoskins
down the left field line that's in for
basin it's a two two-run
double and the phillies are on top three
nothing
they're not hitting it hard but they're
hitting them where we ain't zach
wheeler's got a lead now three nothing
as we start the sixth inning
swinging a miss 98
eight strikeouts for wheeler he's
retired 13 in a row
back toward the middle right at segura
this will be 4-3 on the foot out that's
14 straight
retired by zach wheeler he's been
dominant today eight strikeouts through
six weeks
so two free passes in the
walk in the hit bassman it'll leave it
up to zach wheeler
big hit in the fifth inning gave the
fills a one-nothing lead let's see if he
does it here
line drive down the left field line
that's a face hit going to the corner
one run is in it's an rbi
double for zach wheeler he's doing it
all he has more hits than the braves do
four-nothing phillies wow bases are
loaded for the second straight at bat
for reese hoskins
breaking ball struck him out and rhys
hoskins thought that ball was up racy's
been calling it up there all game long
braves only have one hit off zach
wheeler who's been brilliant today
he has retired 14 in a row to the right
side again
segora gobbles it up and throws out all
beasts
that's 15 straight retired by zach
wheeler
and it brings freddie freeman to the
plate swag in a miss
strikeout number nine and that's
16 in a row the 90th pitch of the day
swing and a miss number nine
as far as double digits strikeouts they
know that it's three outs
the inning is over ten strikeouts
17 consecutive hitters he wanted to keep
on going
it's been that kind of day during the
course of zach wheeler's career he has
never
had an outing where he's allowed only
one hit and what a line for wheeler
seven innings one hit no walks ten
nearest will come on and work as atlanta
has been set down
20 in a row coming into the ninth swing
and a miss
struck him out on three pitches
strike three on the outside part of the
plate
a little paint from hector 22 in a row
retired by philly's pitching
and a cold strike three on the inside
corner
hector naris is just struck out the side
and the phillies pitchers zach wheeler
archie bradley
and hector naris have combined on a
one-hit shutout in game two of the
season
as the phillies win it four nothing